[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité avec à la une
cette semaine le bien-être animal que ce
soit pour le corps et l'esprit les
animaux ont aussi le droit à la quiétude
nous montrera t elle cette dans la loi
dans quelques instants recourir aux
chevaux ou machine sans moteur et faire
vivre les pratiques d'autres fois c'est
la passion d'un agriculteurs sarthois à
reportage à suivre dans ce journal de
lmtv sarthe et puis dans ce journal nous
partirons à la découverte et à l'époque
des chevaliers et des templiers c'est
l'un des plus beaux villages de france
la couvertoirade ou découvriront un
sujet et des images sublimes devient
occitanie avoir enfin d'édition
ils sont plus de 15000 chaque année à
être abandonné les animaux de compagnie
sont les principales victimes des
départs en vacances une donnée
malheureuse qu'on pensait néanmoins par
une prise de conscience de plus en plus
importante sur le bien-être animal
exemple dans la loire où les animaux ont
notamment le droit à des séances
d'ostéopathie à reportages et des
explications de ces linars il ya pour la
rédaction de tl7 regarder
pepsi et la jument de 22 ans de vanessa
et pour cette propriétaire il est
indispensable de s'occuper du bien-être
de sa mamie elle a régulièrement recours
aux services d'une ostéopathe pour
s'assurer qu'elle n'ait pas de mots
musculaire ou au ce c'est une tendance
qui est d'actualité et c'est très très
bien les gens font de plus en plus
d'attention à leurs animaux à leur
bien-être à leurs besoins et ça c'est
impeccable parce que il ya des choses
qui sont importantes on peut pas monter
sur le dos d'un cheval sans savoir s'il
a mal ou pas pepsi passe donc sous les
mains expertes de pauline baril son
activité est relativement jeune mais
elle est de plus en plus plébiscités par
les propriétaires d'animaux chaque mois
elle peut en voir entre 60 et 90 en
consultation des animaux comme les
chiens qui apprécie particulièrement le
moment comme prisca pauline c'est cibler
les problèmes tout en respectant les
besoins de ses passions
ya une petite appréhension parce que
souvent maj mes mains la wizo mal mais
s'est vite dissipée quand ils voient que
finalement on y va doucement et que je
respecte aussi leur
les limites qui me fixe quand ils disent
qu'ils ont mal
essayé vraiment fait de rester sur le
seuil de douleur et si les propriétaires
sont de plus en plus attentifs au bien
être physique de leurs animaux l'aspect
psychique est aussi une préoccupation
marie-jo raynaud sabots et
comportementaliste félin une discipline
peu connue finalement et pourtant le
chat il est un peu considéré comme un
comme un meuble dans la maison alors que
lui il a des vrais besoins il a besoin
d'interaction dans le jeu par exemple il
a besoin il a besoin aussi d'avoir des
coins à lully la comportementaliste va
établir un programme avec les
propriétaires pour changer des
comportements gênants comme le dépôt du
rin en dehors de la caisse ou
l'agressivité des comportements qui ont
pu se développer lors des derniers
confinement alors que l'on soit chiens
chats ou bien cheval les propriétaires
d'animaux s'accorde souvent sur une
chose leur compagnon mérite une
attention particulière pour être bien
dans leur tête autre tendance qui
connaît un succès grandissant depuis des
années le zéro déchet une pratique qui
vise à réduire notre impact sur
l'environnement dans les yvelines la
prise de conscience a notamment touché
une mère et sa fille qui ont décidé de
lancer leur gamme de produits bleu blanc
vert c'est son nom des produits naturels
pour l'entretien de la maison un sujet
de justin brasier pour tv 78 la chaîne
des yvelines
bonjour bienvenue faible en verre
société artisanale implanté au vésinet
bleu blanc vert fabrique des produits
d'entretien ménagers écologiques ont
zéro déchet véronique et constance mère
et fille se sont lancées suite à des
problèmes de santé vous savez mais a
longtemps qu'on sait des produits dans
des produits d'entretien avec ma mère
parce que moi j'ai des problèmes
d'eczéma et ma mère a des problèmes de
thyroïde et on voulait du coup faire
découvrir ces produits là notre
entourage donc à la fin du premier
confinement on s'est dit qu'on allait se
passer bleu blanc vert propose huit
produits qu'ils sont réalisés avec peu
d'ingrédients une composition
transparente comme cette lessive
fabriqués à partir d'eau de savon de
marseille de bicarbonate de soude et de
cristaux sud alors là on est en train de
préparer la lessive envoyer l'eau elle
chauffe et on va mettre dedans
le savon de marseille naturelles ou
encore sega les là sont calés détartrant
pour les toilettes
toujours avec quatre ingrédients
uniquement tout est naturel jusqu'à la
colle fabriqués maison l'entreprise a
recours à l'économie circulaire
l'emballage est consigné ou réalisés à
partir de récupération
ici rien n'est laissé au hasard jusqu
aux graphismes on a que du noir pour
éviter des couleurs al impression qu
est-ce que c'est très polluant les
couleurs a l'impression que je vais
faire attention à ce que pour une source
noir qu'on retrouve en mono couleurs
le zéro déchet un mode de vie qui tient
à coeur à véronique elle livre ses
astuces sur le compte instagram de bleu
blanc vert pour sensibiliser
avec ma lessive je n'utilise pas de
plastique et en fait je fais aussi
attention non seulement à la planète
qu'on va laisser à nos enfants mais
aussi à l'intérêt individuel aux gens
chaque à chaque personne puisque nos
produits sont aussi sans matières
toxiques donc bonne pour la santé essayé
aussi c'est très important pour moi
dernier produit en date pour la marque
le stick détachant
voilà et réduire son empreinte sur
l'environnement cela passe aussi par sa
garde-robe à ce propos cet été vous
pourriez essayer le maillot de bain & co
responsable en corse vous allez le voir
une jeune créatrice a lancé l'an dernier
sa marque de maillots de bain fabriqué à
partir de filets de pêche recyclé
objectif proposer des pièces tendances
tout en prenant soin des océans les
explications de la créatrice lors d'une
séance photo elle répondait aux
questions d'arnaud baazi aidant jours
s'il y devient telle est pas aisé
le concept c'est l'éco responsabilité je
fabrique les maillots de bain ils
activaient rossi avec un tissu italien
qui est de grande qualité et qui est
fabriqué à partir de filets de pêche et
déchets océanique qui sont recyclées
régénérer ça me tenait à coeur de
trouver un tissu éco-responsable et
d'avoir une démarche soucieuse de
l'environnement dans une chaîne de
production assez courte c'est la marque
qui a créé sa qui se charge de récolter
tous ces déchets dans les fonds marins
et ensuite de commencer le processus de
recyclage leur régénération
restons près de la plage dans cette
édition pour découvrir des produits de
la mer exploité au format snacking assez
étonnant de prime abord ce concept se
veut pratique et accessible
objectif proposer des plats rapides et
simples à base de poisson de burgers de
sandwichs ou encore de salades à monaco
un restaurant développe une offre bio
est fait maison reportage de la
rédaction de monaco un four ils sont
trois les deux amis co gérant rémi et
ricardo ainsi que la chef sahara il
propose une offre inédite dans les
halles de la place d'armes juste
derrière la poissonnerie en face du
comptoir une offre originale de
restauration nous avons créé ce concept
autour du poisson nous on travaille donc
le stacking autour du poisson on va
travailler le poisson sous différentes
formes on sait bien cru puis également
charcuterie sur forme des sandwichs et
là ça fait deux ans qu'on a travaillé
sur ce projet là et on a voulu proposer
vraiment un format de snacking c'est à
dire qu'il soit très abordable ce soit
pour tout le monde tous puissent s'y
retrouver l'idée c'était également 2
de transmettre aussi des valeurs que nos
familles nous ont transmises par exemple
celle de rémy qui travaillent dans le
poisson depuis quatre ou cinq
générations autant la mienne qui est une
famille de paysans donc c'était l'idée
spectra et des produits sains loeb un
burger au poisson fait maison avec
l'arrivage du jour des salades et une du
ceviche du tartare du tata qui mais
également et c'est original de la
charcuterie de la mer que l'on appelle
donc de la mercury damart cutri en fait
ça va être en retour un petit peu à des
procédés de transformation et de
conservation ancestrales donc c'est à
dire que on va travailler le poisson
même manière que de la charcuterie
classique sauf que là on va être sur des
produits qui vont être beaucoup plus
riche en protéines riche en eau mega cd
produits qui sont entièrement travaillé
à la main également par exemple on va
avoir un produit qui plaît énormément
qui va être la mortadelle de ton et de
sèche on a également
la bresaola du jambon d'espadon sont
vraiment des produits très centré noble
et on va avoir bientôt aussi de nouveaux
arrivages on va avoir du kebab de ton on
va avoir beaucoup de déclinaisons comme
ça de grands classiques dans le format
poisson voilà pour tout ce qui sort des
océans pour le reste maison mère est
livrée pour cet essai appétissant ainsi
que ses légumes frais et de saison sans
oublier les boissons qui s'inscrivent
dans une démarche environnementale comme
par exemple les canettes baptisée océan
52 dont 52% du chiffre d'affaires du
distributeur est reversée à la recherche
et à la protection des océans
monaco la côte d'azur et ses célébrités
font la une des grands magazines depuis
toujours parmi eux paris match reste la
référence en france nous avons le
plaisir d'être en duplex avec caroline
mangeuse la directrice de la rédaction
de paris match bonjour caroline manger
dit ok nous pourquoi paris match est un
magazine de proximité
finalement très très lu ment région
je crois que parce que paris match est
un journal
emblématique de la france c'est un
journal populaire et en fait ça a été un
des premiers hebdomadaire français c'est
un journal qu'on peut laisser sur la
table du salon dans les maisons sans que
les gens soient heurtés et on a eu
toutes ces stars qui sont très
emblématique de delon à johnny etc pour
lesquels match était un peu leur leur
journal et qui sont des gens qui ont un
succès fou partout en province qui
faisait des tournées en province et si
tu as donc on a on a collé à ces gens
que les gens aimés et du coup on a
embarqué toute la france est caroline
l'ont ges comment décidez-vous de la
ligne éditoriale de paris-match des
priorités que vous allez donner à tel ou
tel sujet alors on décide c'est assez
simple de décider de la ligne éditoriale
de paris match puisque paris ja match
est un journal qui a été un petit peu
définis par cette formule que tout le
monde connaît qui est le poids des mots
le choc des photos donc dans match on
raconte des histoires
la ligne éditoriale c'est quels
personnages ont choisi ou pas après la
une de match c'est toujours un petit peu
un tableau 2 honneur donc on a un peu
évolué ces dernières années en mettant
des personnages ou d'aider des gens
comme fourniret qui n'est pas ne mérite
pas du tout un tableau d'honneur mais
néanmoins
on met en couverture de match des gens
que tout le monde connaît sur la manière
de raconter sans paris match mais on
fait du storytelling ça veut dire que on
vous explique des choses extrêmement
compliqué parfois mais on passe toujours
par des personnages et on amène toujours
la preuve en image de ce qu on dit
qu'elle est aujourd'hui la part du
numérique pour votre titre pour paris
match on a eu longtemps une stratégie
qui était différente qui était de faire
du flux et de se prendre un peu pour des
raids une rédaction qu'on n'était pas
aujourd'hui on a une offre numérique
payante nouvelle qui ressemble à notre
univers qui ressemble à nos sujets qui
est dans le storytelling qui est dans
nos oeufs dans dans les maîtres du monde
qui aidant les royals etc et qui est je
pense et qui repose aussi sur d'autres
trésors qui ce que sont nos archives et
notre tradition
merci karl une mangeuse d'avoir été
l'invitée du grand jt des territoires je
rappelle que vous êtes entré la
directrice de la rédaction de paris
match et vous étiez d'ailleurs en duplex
du studio de paris match aller remontons
dans le temps dans ce journal pour
découvrir ou re découvrir d'anciennes
machines agricoles c'est l'histoire
d'une passion celle de serge vallée que
je vais vous conter maintenant un
agriculteur de la sarthe amoureux des
chevaux de trait et de l'agriculture à
l'ancienne dans son champ il cultive
chaque année plus de 2 tonnes de pommes
de terre uniquement avec le travail de
ces chevaux et de ces vieilles machines
agricoles
un reportage anthony python pour un mtv
sortent regarder
ça c'est un brabant à deux chevaux c'est
à dire que il est réversible
alors ça ça s'appelle une robe bleue
c'était pour
récupérer le point qui avait des fans
aiment la collection de serge raconte
une époque celle de l'agriculture des
années 50 avant les tracteurs ces
machines sont toutes en état de marche
c'est surtout une valeur sentimentale
puisque tous ces gens qui ont travaillé
avec ça à l'époque où il avait que ça
pour se servir je pense qu'ils ont été
très très méritants
le point commun entre six engins ils
sont les vestiges du temps de la
traction animale dans les travaux
agricoles dans son champ serge lui
continue de labourer à l'ancienne avec
les chevaux de trait une personne ne
veut se servir des chevaux je ne peux
sur les chevaux parce que les chevaux
c'est bien mais il faut qu'ils soient
éduqués pour pouvoir travailler comme
ils travaillent là s'il fallait vivre du
travail des chevaux que moi je travaille
je ne peux qu'en ville il ya l'entretien
du chevalier le maréchal il ya le
vétérinaire et le suivi sanitaire
5 ou un coût qui n'est rien à côté de
son immense plaisir de perpétuer un
savoir-faire et de revivre une partie de
sa jeunesse j'ai travaillé avec les
shows mois jusqu'à 14 ans c'était une
très très belle époque
tous les voisins s'entraidaient tout le
monde se donner la main tout le monde
maintenant elles peuvent pas donner la
main parce qu'ils n'ont plus le temps de
se donner la mort
c'est tu as dit que nous à cette époque
là tous les voisins s'entraidaient la
moisson les battages cdas a duré un mois
donc c'était
y avait pas de
zizanie on peut trouver maintenant entre
l'oise à
aller dans le futur le collectionneur
n'exclut pas d'organiser des
démonstrations mais son souhait le plus
cher ça serait de transmettre pour que
la tradition ne disparaissent pas
l'amour des traditions nous conduit dans
les vosges maintenant dans un atelier
hors du temps celui d'un artisan italien
qui consacre sa vie à la reproduction de
reliques bouton d'uniformes vêtements
pièces de monnaie rien ne se perd tout
se restaurent et tous se fabriquent ou
ceux refabrique reportage d'hélène le
plat pour vous jeter les visions
travailler dans le temps et plongée dont
le passé c'est la traduction même en
latin de labour temporis le nom de
l'atelier créé en 2016 par ce fondeur
d'art dans le village de remous ville
près de neuf châteaux et rendre visite à
marco disaro c'est traverser les âges
cet artisan d'origine italienne s'est
spécialisé dans la reproduction d'objets
historiques sur une période couvrant
l'antiquité à la première guerre
mondiale il fabrique par exemple des
boutons d'uniformes des armées
napoléoniennes ou des monnaies de l'
empire romain jeune il se prend de
passion pour les reconstitutions
historiques et décide avec des amis de
vivre à l'époque médiévale à
reconstruire les habitants des notre
ville
des habitants sans clou à la pad est
riche à l'époque et donc on a commencé
comme ça où à la fin du xiiie siècle
après on est passé par passion au
premier empire napoléonien parce qu'il y
avait des
des régiments italiens qui sont
combattus pour la france pour vivre
pleinement sa passion de l'histoire
marco disaro va suivre une formation aux
bijouteries et se spécialiser dans la
fonderie d'art de métaux légers non
ferreux dans son atelier il réalise ses
moules selon la technique de la fonte à
cire perdue d'où sortiront des pièces de
l'époque choisie comme cette boucle de
ceinture romaine le geste lui non plus
n'a quasiment pas changé ses charges
impôts la forme les matériaux des outils
mais à la fin j'ai plus ou moins les
mêmes j'ai par de la documentation
d'origine disons un peu près aux 80% des
pièces même plus aidez-la avec les
démissions les matériels et la forme je
vais à récréer l'objet
les articles sont remarquables de
précision fabriqués essentiellement les
tons ou en bronze marco di caro possède
ainsi toute une collection de pièces de
monnaie antiques
c'est un des premiers caisse
avec ça on peut tuer quelqu'un
c'est rend très très lourd et très gros
ça c'était un des premiers pièces en
bronze les sesterces en fait ces petits
objets en série ou à l'unité sont
commercialisés en ligne essentiellement
auprès de musée un monde de connaisseurs
et sur l'époque choisie par l'artisan
italien pour ses créations ils sont
moins d'une dizaine en france a exercé
comme lui ce métier original
rêver et voyager en musique cela
pourrait être l'adage de sébastien baron
un artiste breton ce poète et musicien a
décidé de se rendre en exploration au
groenland à bord d'un voilier tout jaune
poussin c'est son nom servira de caisse
de résonance à sa pratique culturelle et
à des rencontres avec les populations
locales départ prévu pour le nord l'an
prochain explication un reportage de
clerville y allons pour tvr à rennes
bienvenue voici poussins le voilier avec
lequel je vais partir guen membre
l'année prochaine et lui c'est sébastien
baron un drôle d'artiste qui a décidé
d'aller au bout d'un rêve peu commun
j'imaginais un tout petit bateau et je
ne sais pas pourquoi mais je l'imaginé
jaune et naturellement c'est devenu
poussins et poussins basse pour moi
c'est aussi quelque chose de mignon puis
un poussin sur la banquise qui est le
titre le nom du projet tuteuré de ça
avait du sens ce flibustier des tons
moderne n'en est pas à sa première
traversée se fait un premier voyage dans
les eaux chaudes et puis
donc là j'ai eu cette envie cette vision
d'aller naviguer dans les glaces est
allé à la rencontre des populations
inuits du groenland pour mener à bien ce
projet sébastien fait construire un
voilier sur mesure dans un matériel très
résistant li negra basalte et il a pensé
à tout aussi on est dans le carré de
poussins ont l'espace intérieur l'espace
de vie et donc a été conçue dès le
départ un endroit ici même pour m un
instrument de musique et pas n'importe
lequel moi si mon fidèle compagnon de
route
protéger des chocs son fidèle accordéon
pourra l'accompagner partout car son
expédition est un savant mélange nautico
artistique l'idée c'est de créer un ciné
concert au retour du voyage avec des
images que je vais prendre pendant le
voyage mais également à la construction
il ya déjà des images qui ont été
tournées et ensuite l'idée c'est de
créer de la musique sur ces images là
que je vais pouvoir diffuser dans divers
lieux
[Musique]
dans des cinémas dans des médias
thaïlandais salle de spectacle le départ
est prévu en avril 2023 et sébastien
cherche encore des sponsors pour
financer son périple musical et poétique
et en l'écoutant on se dit que la
banquise a bien de la chance
pourquoi
voilà est plus proche de chez nous à
metz il est aussi possible de naviguer
sur l'eau tout en musique et en histoire
c'est en tout cas la promesse d'un
capitaine qui embarque ses hôtes lors
d'une balade sur la moselle est
l'occasion de découvrir le patrimoine
local sa faune et sa flore une escapade
poétique à l'heure de l'apéritif à
laquelle s'est jointe chloé gaillard de
moselle télévision à regarder sur le
quai des régates à metz une dizaine
d'aventuriers s'est retrouvé pour deux
heures de balade sur la moselle dans une
ambiance feu de camp le capitaine robbie
s'apprête à lever l'ancré sur sa petite
calédonie s'il peut t'il commuter et
patrimoine et nature sont originaires de
la région et j'ai redécouvert metz comme
un touriste et je me suis rendu compte
qu'on avait la chance d'avoir une ville
magnifique avec un riche patrimoine avec
une nature exceptionnelle
à la barre le chef de bord se plaît à
faire découvrir l'histoire la nature et
le patrimoine local un moment apprécié
par les navigateurs abbas est un vrai
moment de bonheur c'est vraiment un
moment de sérénité c'est un vraiment
vraiment un très très bon moment c'est
quelque chose qui passe là sur sept sur
sept rivières il ya ya de la poésie de
la lumière il ya il ya de la vie
il ya la diversité en passer ce
magnifique quoi en plus de déguster un
verre de vin de moselle et quelques
amuse gueule en court-circuit le petit
comité se délecte d'un concert
acoustique intime
le partage et la convivialité sont les
maîtres mots de cet instant une vraie
relation de proximité qui se fait avec
le public parfois il ya des amis à bord
parfois des gens que je connais pas du
tout et voilà c'est un vrai havre de
paix un petit moment suspendu comme ça
au bord de l'eau et avec des gens super
sympa comme le capitaine et puis tous
les gens qui sont là si les marins d'eau
douce profite en toute sérénité c'est en
partie grâce à leur embarcation solaire
où on est autonome obligé de charger à
quai avec lequel août à l'électricité on
peut recharger à quai mais du juste avec
les panneaux solaires il est autonome on
peut alors on va naviguer les batteries
se sont chargés toute la journée on est
autonome de quoi admirer et écouter la
cité messine depuis ses parties les plus
sauvages jusqu'à la vieille ville
illuminée fièrement gardé par son
célèbre temple je le conseillerai à des
touristes évidemment mais mais surtout à
des locaux parce que on voit jamais la
ville de la même façon quand on la
découvre sur l'eau cette escapade
poétique est à savourer tout au long de
l'été chaque mardi soir une occasion
d'admirer un beau coucher de soleil ou
un envol de signes
[Musique]
voilà refermant ce journal à présent
avec la découverte d'une splendeur de
notre patrimoine national en occitanie
l'histoire du village de la
couvertoirade est synonyme d'histoire et
d' aventure cité bâtie par les taupes
liés au 12e siècle la couvertoirade
entraîne ses visiteurs dans une plongée
au coeur de l'histoire et des croisades
une immersion au temps du moyen âge dans
laquelle nous conduit anne-sophie
pélégry de la rédaction devient
occitanie un reportage éblouissant vous
allez le voir
tous les chemins mènent à la
couvertoirade mais à cela son village
fortifié
[Musique]
bâti sur le plateau du larzac en aveyron
la cité de la couvertoirade fondée par
l'ordre des templiers a comme un air de
légende c'est en montant sur cette
éponge naturelle qu'on arrive au coeur
de l'histoire
c'est vraiment là le temps des eaux des
templiers vraiment c'est la partie
historique la plus ancienne château
templiers xiiie siècle en occident les
templiers se voit attribuer de
nombreuses terres de culture et
d'élevage dont les revenus sont destinés
à la guerre menée en terre sainte le
plateau du larzac constitue une base
stratégique pour les chevaliers du
temple car située à une centaine de km
des portes lieux d'embarcation des
croisés le seigneur de mon banc va
donner c'était peu rond rocheux l'a
perdu au milieu de rien aux templiers
qui eux vont nous ériger ce château qui
est un peu une énigme pour les italiens
parce que c'est le dernier unique
château templiers que met en france
alors pourquoi sur cet éperon rocheux
pas parce que on domine donc on pouvait
défendre naturellement et puis surtout à
la couvertoirade il y à quelque chose
d'essentiel sur le larzac c'est une
grande réserve d'eau pendant plusieurs
siècles les habitants auront d'accès à
l'eau potable grâce à ce rocher mais
aussi à l'aménagement d'un village conçu
avec une obsession la récupération de
l'eau
la couvertoirade a tiré profit d'un
terrain pentu pour drainer les eaux de
plus à l'est de kano jusqu'à cette
lavognes et permettra aussi aux bêtes de
se désaltérer ce n'est qu'en 1975 que le
village a accès à l'eau courante et
cette villageoise se souvient bien de
cette période j'avais donc peu de peu
d'eau il fallait faire attention
en allait enfin et puis tous les gens du
village les jambes il villages qui
n'avaient pas de citernes dont se
retrouver à la chicane municipal de
seclin week end un an et demi
christiane est arrivé à la couvertoirade
en 1971 avec son métier à tisser les
motos étaient déjà sur place et s'il
architecture du village est construite
autour de l'eau les maisons sont
aménagés autour du mouton souvent une
voûte et où il ya les bêtes et au dessus
il ya une pièce d'habitation est tout en
haut un grenier ou aux mails fois on
vivait ici du mouton ça c'est le rocher
le mur là au bout c'est le rocher qui a
été taillée c'est grâce aux bêtes que
les hospitaliers faisait vivre le
village après l'éradication du trop
puissantes ordre des templiers par
philippe le bel ce sont eux qui prennent
en charge la gestion de la cité et
construit ses remparts tous ces
témoignages de notre temps sont
précieusement entretenue par les
habitants de la couvertoirade du château
des templiers aux vestiges les plus
récents comme ce moulin à vent qui
aujourd'hui n'a besoin que d'un meunier
pour mot dans son blé chaque année ce
sont plus de 230 mille visiteurs qui
découvrent des plus beaux villages
france sur une terre classés au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]